we don't know about that we know that
she was a virgin woman yes
you see one of the Miracles of Quran and
why is that make more sense than
Christianity
Mary she got pregnant with Jesus correct
the way that was created
Adam from no mother no father
is it
yeah
then if she was created from from Adam
from his trip yeah but the point here is
God wants to show us is powerful that
his power is not restricted so God
create a human being without a man or a
woman
then it could create another human being
from a woman not a man then God creates
another human being from a woman not a
man to show you that Allah is more
powerful that doesn't mean if she's a
daughter of God because now she has no
she came from a man not a woman likewise
he doesn't need Adam he called his
father and his mother God create us in a
different ways you understand for
example now when you look back to the
story of Jesus or Mary
according to the Hebrew or to the
Israelites if you commit adultery what
is the punishment
in the Old Testament King James
if a woman have intercourse having sex
outside marriage or adultery you still
not to death all right so now imagine
Mary coming with a child to the rabbis
and she said I have a child you're gonna
say okay who do you got to charge for
that's why the quranic
narrative is more miracle and makes
sense what is the quranic narrative The
quranic Narrative that Allah made
because when she brought the Jesus to
them they said to her how can you have a
son with no matter statue
she pointed at the child in the Cradle
and the extra charge spoke and he said
on the servant of Allah so what would
Allah gave her a miracle in order to
protect her from the story to death
but when it comes to Christianity
narrative she got she got married to
George of the carpenter
I had gone
she having the baby before she comes
you know she's already pregnant
but the quranic story makes more sense
because Allah would Allah put people
through tests Allah will Aid his beloved
ones that's why in the Quran there's a
chapter called chapter of marriage
Muhammad
because why Prophet Muhammad is going to
name a chapter after someone owes mother
there's not a need of that you know why
because
Muhammad migrated too
in Medina the Israelites they were dead
he could have agreed with the Jews there
but he went against them by defended
Jesus and there was no any need for him
to defend Jesus rather if it was a false
prophet he should have
go go and then and and back up or go in
line with the statement of the Jewish
people to gain more followers but he was
against them why because Prophet
Muhammad doesn't know even respond
desires is in the Revelation so to come
to to summarize
this is a proof that prophet Muhammed is
a messenger of Allah there's a chapter
in the Quran named of the mother of
Jesus that shows you will love Jesus
will love his mother you know also if
why Prophet Muhammad is going to defend
Jesus in Jesus in Medina
when there was no need for him to defend
him if he was a false prophet
to show you that Prophet Muhammad is a
message of Allah and this book Quran the
Quran was not made by him
and like I show you the narrative for
panic narrative about Jesus and his
mother makes more sense it's more
Miracle Than The Narrative of the Bible
can I ask you something who wrote the
Bible the New Testament
I mean John Mark Luke
Matthew
I'm bored I don't know what you're going
to do I don't know which one will be
disciples none of the devil disciples
there were people came after like for
example look clearly said people pass
down delicious to him so look at Matthew
and Mark and Paul Paul remember Paul
used to go around kill the cushions
yes but the pointy and none of them they
were Disciples of Jesus
none of them they came after this I'll
write it and again even the Bible we
don't have the original writing of the
Bible
like Jesus never spoke English
Jesus
so where is it that the real and the the
original teacher of Jesus in his
language we don't have this
and you know about the concept of loss
in translation
I mean King James
King James is based upon a manuscript
that was written 100 years after we
don't know who wrote it
that's why the Miracles are foreign
will never be lost
for the Bible like I said Jesus never
spoke Greek spoke different language we
don't have Ursula writing even if we do
have it we have not trace it back
because the writers are known
so you want to worship God correct
yeah would you worship God according to
a book that you don't know what and you
put into a book that they corrupted or
you worship of God according to a book
that is still pure and preserved
the Bible is it is a Islamic Quran yeah
why are you doing with the Old Testament
second if you see if you see um
what are you doing with the Old
Testament so why do the Old Testament
because when I speak to Christians and
they don't believe what I'm going to say
to them so I showed them my claims I
back it up I don't follow the Bible
look
because sometimes you know you cannot
tell Christian the Bible said such and
such how do you know I was watching the
documentary no you have to back up yeah
so I use the proof of the study it I
studied many times
I have this one and I have ESV
I mean I'm not sure if you you know what
is difference between the two
okay there's some passages here it's not
here
so I don't know which one is that the
word of God is this one or this one for
example I'll tell you this phone is very
famous about Jesus you know when they
approach the woman adultera woman to
Jesus
and he said the word would never commit
a sin Let Him cast the first stone yeah
he was out sin Let Him cast the first
though the first one yeah that story is
fabricated
this book
my dear brothers and sisters as you know
we are we have a campaign to raise the
money for our Masjid or to buy a new
place because as you know the current
place that we have behind the market
subhanallah I believe you did see or if
you haven't seen it yet go back to our
Channel
and see it the place is very terrible
but like it's very hard to walk through
it's not safe for women or children to
come so we are raising money we haven't
found a place yet but what happened we
are raising money because what happened
in the past if you don't find if you do
find the place we don't have enough
money for deposits so we raise and
manage Allah while we are still looking
for a new place so make sure you have us
may Allah bless you oh difference
between these two books
this book is based upon area manuscripts
earlier manuscript yeah so the earliest
manuscripts
the early Smith doesn't mean go back to
Jesus time me is that earlier than this
manuscript here doesn't have that story
but there so the Christian scholar said
it was added later on
for example if you go Matthew 17 21 is
not here Matthew 17 21 but it's in King
James
let me make it clear I'm not talking
about a different translation no there
is God literally if you open let me make
it clear to you I'll show you you know
what Matthew 17 21 yeah
watch this
try to read Matthew 17 21.
it's only 17 21 isn't there try to find
it yeah
foreign
is Matthew 17 all right okay so let us
come
here yeah 20 okay so what is 21.
yeah it was 20 21
Matthew 17 21 yeah there's no 21 here
look there's no there's not Barry no
mask prescriptions
the footnotes
let me show you come okay
all right so this is Matthew 19 yeah
that's 20. that's not 21 okay then we
carry on we carry on 22. there's not 21.
but here it was the number and there's
no 21 it comes here look it tells me
uh
oh this is
[Music]
so you come you can't even see it all
right
21 is not here there's 22.
okay but there's five yeah so when you
go fruit nuts
uh three okay with some manuscripts
inside dress 21.
so please
let me get rid of it
but it tells you here some manuscripts
inserts mean that the added to it
is here but it's not dead
but the time never come out
uh my sons or my son my or the Beloved
Greek
I don't understand this it says it says
basically all right some manuscripts in
verse 21 but this kind never comes out
except by prayer and fasting some
manuscripts remained
Avatar a silver coin worth four
dramas or approximately one shekel
so it's not here 21 is not here but it
tells you why they never put it because
some manuscripts added data
so my point here is that you have two
Bibles literally there's more
there's more examples when you have some
passages missing at all because why it
was added people started playing around
with the manuscripts and that's what
Allah mentioned in the Quran that the
people of the book they start adding the
description
and now we have just discovered we have
discovered many manuscripts see that so
how existed 1 000 400 years ago was able
to come with this information with
during his lifetime he never had access
to other manuscript to come to to know
that
but now we know that for fact there's
many manuscripts different very
different from each other
that's why look
what we say to you that you agreed that
you want to worship God according to
book as we Preserve
and it's pure
and that cannot be the Bible
cannot be Hinduism Buddhism only come to
Islam
the Quran he mentioned that Allah made
it easy for the people to memorize it
foreign
you know Britain there is how many
Muslims how many Christians in Britain
now the last three that way yes in
Britain remember bro you're from you're
from Grenada you're from Caribbean
Christianity was brought to you by the
Europeans
because Christianity was forced upon you
by these people these people who came to
Africa as well who tried to force
Christianity on us have left it they're
running away from it they are nowhere
from it the people that forced
Christianity on other nations they left
it completely
they realize that doesn't make any sense
you understand but when you come to
Islam now there's more Muslim the Islam
is increasing in Britain cruciality is
declined even though bro what's your
name
is
even though there's a huge war against
Islam
there's a huge war against Islam on
social media everywhere but the fastest
growing religion on the face of the
earth is Islam you know what Allah is
doing the job bro
We Believe Allah is one pure perfect
in the Old Testament God regrets God is
he perfect
in the Quran Allah is perfect is one
doesn't give birth to no one and no one
give birth to him and there is nothing
like unto him you know
Prophet Muhammad prophecy that he
prophesies about the future we can see
it right now
many many examples
what do you think was said so far
you can call it it yeah because I was
thinking how are you coming out of a
T-shirt bro
what do you think was said
I think
what you're saying in the Quran
some of you a lot of videos in the Bible
as well for example
for example
say
God Mary
oh god oh Jesus
yeah
but the quranic story like I said it
makes more sense it's more Miracle than
the story in the Bible and I don't I
don't negate there's some truth in the
Bible by the way not only gay there is
some truth in the Bible however it was
corrupted later God by the Romans which
is the New Testament as for the Old
Testament I can show you many
Corruptions of the Old Testament
that's the question I'm going to ask you
does God regrets
you know he's regretting regret when you
do something and you regret it because
you never knew the outcome of it
due to your lack of knowledge
you chose something then you come to
conclusion what I have chosen was wrong
why you didn't know because you don't
have enough knowledge
so if God regrets that his imperfection
is knowledge
who has no regrets
regrets is like you wish you never chose
that option
that is imperfection that is in the
Bible yes
that one and also God greatly regrets
for choosing son as a king
and Samuel when God said to to Seoul to
serve you said he will kill the babies
and infants
another story
go kill babies and infants
the malachites
yeah
and he's a computer then Cody said I
greatly a statement we don't believe
that I greatly regret for choosing Soul
as a king so God chose it then God
regrets for choosing him that's not good
well there's no regret
whatever Allah choose for us and for
himself is perfect
who do you regret is human nature to
regrets
do you understand also how the language
came about why we speak different
languages
one of them was um
[Music]
I may god Set Me Down
not even like us so what he did he make
everybody yeah so and then what happened
is that everybody start fighting against
each other
um the people have to speak the same
language for the same direction and
people are everybody basically does
speak the same language
they're their way I mean you you have
some you know it's about all how it
starts it
sounds Babylon yes they will speak in
one language and there's a bit in tall
buildings
so God he said people are speaking one
language and be the two buildings
nothing can stop them
so he said the angel to cause confusion
if you know about history
the the the the the people the the
Sumerians Sumerians and The Time Of The
Babylon they used to believe if you
build two buildings you'll be able to
reach God and overthrow God
but we know now regardless how so
beautiful how it's already going to
build buildings you will never be able
to reach God so the Genesis shows you
that the person who said the Buffalo
ability
yeah it shows it he doesn't know the
distance between the Heaven and the sky
also who doesn't worry in those people
speak one language
said
but Allah said through his prophet all
mankind
and even the demon the Jinn if all of
you come together and you have the most
evil hearts that will not harm me but
will not become worry you're gonna harm
yourself
and if you come all together and you
have the most righteous hearts that will
not benefit me
the Quran God
I believe in the god of the Bible about
the code of the Bible the Christ I would
like to guess it
have attributes of lies to him and you
can see the Sprite of the Old Testament
were heavily influenced by the paganism
of Sumerians Babylonians so
looks of God speak one language speak
one letter all together doesn't not
worry good at all
but in the quranic teaching why we speak
different languages that is a sign from
God that God create us to speak
different languages
language
so my point here is Iman look to the
quranic quote how Allah described
himself in a perfect way
to the Old Testament there's a lot of
efficiency like I said there's some
truth in it no doubt but there's a lot
of lies against God her logic dictates
that I'm not going to worship God
according to a book this truth mixed
with a falsehood rather I'm Gonna
Worship God according to the book when
the truth is pure and clear and
not mixed up with a falsehood at all
right
it was nice
food for four yeah I think about it you
know worship God
every Friday we have a leaflet I can
give you three for a second
always
why why is
you can see
there's questions here
you know
[Music]
look
he said of Jesus Son of Mary
where is it
other questions
from the Bible as well Jesus that he
worshiped the worshiper
passages and so on it's for you as a
gift
all right you're welcome